[Musique]
aujourd'hui mercredi 12 octobre retour
sur l'actualité à travers celles et ceux
qui en sont les acteurs au cours de ce
set 8 les invités vous entendrez à
tatiana merabet présidente de
l'association dix fois plus fort parents
et enfants se retrouvent souvent démunis
face aux troubles de l'apprentissage
elle se propose de les aider à magny les
hameaux
ophélie murray président de
l'association la divine comédie elle
mettra le théâtre à l'honneur dans
quelques jours à saint cyr l'école avec
le festival mort de rire et puis
fabrizio être aussi dessinateur de
l'écurie disney il était un but le
week-end dernier lors d'un autre
festival celui ci dédié à la bande
dessinée
la dyslexie dyscalculie dysorthographie
voilà quelques-uns des troubles qui
peuvent toucher les enfants et qui
laisse les parents démunis près de 8%
des petits à partir de 2 3 ans seraient
concernés selon à l'académie de médecine
et pour en parler je reçois aujourd'hui
à tatiana merabet la présidente de
l'association est dix fois plus fort
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
venez de lancer votre association tout
simplement parce que votre fille noémie
10 ans et dyspraxiques elle souffre de
troubles du développement moteur et des
fonctions visio spatiales et c'est donc
votre expérience personnelle qui a
poussé à la création de cette
association tout jeune c'était tôt au
mois de juillet dernier on va revenir
tout d'abord sur votre expérience
personnelle comment été diagnostiquée la
dyspraxie de votre fille à partir de ce
que l'on a vu à l'école et puis à partir
aussi de ce qu'on a vu nous quand elle
évolue à la maison au bout d'un moment
on va commencer à faire des bilans chez
une psychomotricienne ensuite un mineur
toptic ensuite on a fait un bon appel
inclut un bilan
psychométriques et au fur et à mesure de
ces bilans et bien nous sommes allés une
sont montés à d'autres diagnostic plus
poussé sur mignot et à partir de là le
neuro pédiatre à l'égout stick est une
distraction visio spatiales pour l'oin
en général c'est difficile à
diagnostiquer oui il faut que ce soit
établie par un professionnel un euro
pédiatre mais qui a besoin en fait de
l'ensemble des différents diagnostics
mais aussi des des bilans aussi des
enseignants parce qu'ils ont repéré pour
pouvoir vraiment signer là on va devoir
chercher mais ensuite pour aider pour
vous accompagner et puis pour aider nos
amis comment ça s'est passé est ce que
c'est compliqué c'est difficile parce
que nous on pense que diagnostic est
l'étape ultime et non en fait ce n'est
que le début d'un long parcours où il va
falloir faire reconnaître le trouble
chez auprès de l'école pour que
différentes
compensation d'autres compensations
soient faits pour qu'elles puissent
suivre sa scolarité car ce sont des
enfants intelligents on le dit et on le
répète il suffit juste en fait d'adapter
l'ensemble des supports pour qu'on
puisse suivre à l'école et donc quand on
a le diagnostic il faut ensuite que
l'enfant soit accompagnée en dehors de
l'école par différents spécialistes pour
qu'ils puissent apprendre à apprendre
avec ceux qui sont depuis de cette
association c'est justement de venir en
aide aux parents qui comme vous se sont
retrouvés une fois le diagnostic posé
face à face à un désert en fait tout
simplement d'un accompagnement difficile
donc l'association dix fois plus fort
est née justement de l'initiative de
parents et d'enseignants qui est
sensibilisé par les enfants et
adolescents qui ont des troubles des
apprentissages ont décidé justement de
se regrouper et de leur donner des
moyens de les accompagner
les aider de les outiller temps pour la
vie scolaire mais aussi dans leur vie
sociale parce que souvent dans les
salles d'attentes chez les spécialistes
c'est là qu'on se rencontre et on est
complètement effectivement isolées et
démunies la seule association est
installé à magny les hameaux vous
proposer des ateliers créatifs des
accompagnements pour former aussi à tout
l'aspect tout l'aspect numérique parce
que les ordinateurs sont d'un grand
secours pour
enfants dyspraxiques c'est vrai que
l'écriture la lecture et est un lourd
handicap et pour métro tout ce qu'ils
ont dans la tête c'est vrai que le
numérique est un outil incontournable
encore faut-il quand vous faites un
dossier auprès de la mdph vous avez du
matériel mais il faut savoir que tous
les soins tous les à toutes les
personnes qui interviennent certains
sont certains ne sont pas prises en
charge par la sécurité sociale et donc
un ergothérapeute et psychomotricienne
et vous avez beaucoup de familles qui
face à tous ces frais ne peuvent pas
outillée les enfants convenablement donc
on répond d'effectivement d'aider
d'accompagner ces familles en créant des
ateliers numériques en prêtant aussi des
ordinateurs mais c'est aussi à travers
des ateliers créatifs re donner de
l'estimé de la confiance à ses enfants
c'est aussi ouvrir des groupes de parole
pour les enfants et pour les familles
pour se retrouver un dimanche autour
d'un café et discuter métro des mots
échangés sur tous les parcours pour
aussi finalement être plus fort quand on
est tous regroupés les enfants la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il existe des outils
pour aider ses enfants et de leurs
parents mais aider les enfants contre
l'échec scolaire sur la question de cet
échec scolaire la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est peut-être que les pouvoirs publics
n'ont pas saisi l'ampleur du problème
beaucoup de choses qui se mettent en
place dans les écoles
après il faut que la formation suit et
puis et puis il faut aussi et bien aidé
aussi
nombre de familles qui elles n'ont pas
forcément cette culture scolaire parce
que les troubles des apprentissages ça
peut être aussi quelque chose de
discriminante beaucoup de familles la
discrimination c'est ça le aussie qui
est important il faut pour l'enfant
aussi qui se retrouve pas isolée et puis
pour leurs familles et changer le regard
du handicap en fait sur ses enfants mais
aussi sur sur ce qu'ils peuvent apporter
enfin dans la société officie aussi
c'est vraiment ces valeurs aussi qui
sont véhiculées au sein de l'association
si vous voulez en savoir plus il ya une
journée portes ouvertes qui est prévue
dimanche 16 octobre de 14 heures à 18
heures ce sera l'estaminet comment ça va
se dérouler cet après-midi tout
simplement eh bien les différents
intervenants vont proposer différents
ateliers je sais qu on a une enseignante
spécialisée qui va proposer des ateliers
sensoriels pour expérimenter comment on
lit comme un petit lexique comment on
écrit comme un dyspraxiques serge qui
est notre foi car au numérique va
proposer différents jeux et montrer
comment finalement l'apprentissage du
clavier peut se faire on à cathy qui va
proposer aussi des ateliers créatifs sur
la petite boîte à bonheur pour eux de
l'aider steam et puis ensuite un grand
goûter sera proposé
préparé par les amis des stars miner
notre association de mali et donc on
finira la journée avec un café un goûter
un beaucoup d'échangés autour de ses
seins nus merci beaucoup je redonne le
nom de votre association dix fois plus
fort c'est à magny les hameaux et les
portes ouvertes le 16 octobre à
l'estaminet merci à vous nous avons une
page culture à présent avec du théâtre
le théâtre qui sera à l'honneur ce week
end à saint cyr l'école au vendredi
jusqu'à dimanche se tiendra le festival
mort de rire c'est au théâtre gérard
philipe c'est déjà la troisième édition
cinq troupes amateurs vont se produire
avec être différents spectacles comiques
forcément on écoute ophélie mur et c'est
la présidente de l'association la divine
comédie et c'est elle qui organise ce
festival c'est un festival de théâtre
amateur qui regroupe plusieurs troupes
des yvelines et de la france entière et
qui permet de faire connaître un peu le
théâtre et
dans un cadre différent du théâtre
classique on peut apprendre à l'école ou
à l'appui pouvoir promouvoir activités
théâtre dans toutes ses formes et
notamment la comédie alors comique
attention c'est pas des grands éclats de
rire on a du théâtre classique aussi
avec une pièce de molière georges dandin
mais qui une pièce qui est une vraie
comédie classique et on aussi de la
comédie médiévale et puis du théâtre de
boulevard ou la wii c'est c'est des plus
grands éclats de rire mais pourquoi mort
de rire parce que c'est au moment de la
toussaint et donc c'était pour faire un
petit jeu de mot avec ce moment
l'objectif c'était de pouvoir
pouvoir se diversifier à accueillir des
troupes venues d'un peu partout puisque
c'est frustrant quand on est du théâtre
amateur de monter une pièce est de jouer
une fois et après terminer là ça permet
de se faire connaître et de pouvoir
jouer plusieurs fois
une pièce en particulier et d'échangés
entre les trous vendredi soir on a un
premier spectacle le samedi après midi
on a un spectacle à 14 heures avec une
troupe de jouy du 28 une troupe à 17
heures qui vient de versailles est une
troupe à 21h une troupe qui ne vient de
toulouse est une troupe le dimanche à 15
heures pour un nouveau spectacle à
chaque fois c'est un spectacle différent
et une pièce différente la troupe de
saint cyr donc la divine comédie qui
jouera le dimanche après midi à 15
heures présentera hors piste aux
maldives une pièce d'éric delcourt donc
là c'est une vraie comédie
théâtre de boulevard avec des amies qui
se retrouvent sur une île déserte et
c'est un peu le règlement de comptes
entre tout ce petit groupe d'amis c'est
du spectacle tout public
on n'a pas réussi cette année à trouver
un spectacle jeune public
malheureusement mais c'est ouvert à tous
un enfant à partir de 8 ans voilà
jusqu'à voilà droit d'entrée donc 8
euros la place pour les adultes 4 euros
pour les enfants et le pass festival à
25 et 15 euros respectivement pour
assister à tous les spectacles et voter
pour le spectacle et assister à la
remise des prix qui aura lieu le
dimanche rendez-vous tout le week end on
offre un petit cocktail à l'ouverture du
festival le vendredi soir et voilà venez
découvrir le théâtre venez découvrir la
comédie au théâtre et il y en aura pour
tous les goûts nous terminons avec la
23e édition du festival de bande
dessinée à buc c'était le week-end
dernier à cette occasion nous avons
rencontré l'un des dessinateurs présents
fabrizio petroci il est le dessinateur
des personnages du monde de disney
depuis à 20 ans à un héritage qu'il
transmet puisqu'il participe également à
la formation et des jeunes dessinateurs
de l'école dit il était au micro de
nicolas kirillovitch je travaille avec
les personnages de disney sur tous les
personnages
ce qu'on appelle les standards caractère
c'est à dire les personnages de la
famille de mickey donald dingo
et je travaille avec ses personnages
depuis 22 ans j'ai commencé en italie
les années 90 dans le magazine topolino
qui est très connue en italie qui est
très populaire et ensuite j'ai été
embauché dans les studios disney à paris
où j'ai travaillé pendant dix ans donc
j'ai plusieurs possibilités de
travailler avec ces personnages soient
dans l'addition soit le merchandising
cette fois pour le parc que pour tous
j'avais commandé
mes qualités plutôt dans le dessin
humoristique et cartoon plutôt que dans
le dessin réaliste finalement j'ai
choisi je commençais déjà à regarder
la tradition de bande dessinée franco
belge comme astérix
maurice et en même temps on dise n'est
donc j'ai été passionné par les deux et
c'est pour ça j'ai pensé que disney
c'était quand même un style de dessin
qui était beaucoup plus proche
deux mois il ya deux différents types de
public il ya les enfants et les
nostalgiques il ya les enfants qu'ils
aiment qu'ils achètent toujours
rejoindre les maquis ou d'autres
collections disney actuelle et à côté de
ça il ya aussi les fans les gens qui ont
connue disney compte visiter du tout
jeune donc il ya une bonne partie parce
que dans la collection que je dédicace
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
l'intégrale des différents auteurs comme
carbassous docteur sands qui sont des
auteurs du passé donc ces gens là
cca d'aumelas sont toujours acheté par
des par des fans par des nostalgiques la
plupart des légendes bande dessinée soit
picsou soit donald soit mickey soit
c'est ça c'est les trois personnages
comme demande de dessiner le plus
souvent après ça peut arriver qu'au
moment des personnages depuis sont un
peu plus ses compères on va dire comme
dingo plutôt mini une des filles donc
pas mal de mini les filles en général
soit des histoires mini les enfants pour
eux c'est de la magie en fait contient
un personnage qui ce qui qui ce qui se
crée dans les mains d'un dessinateur
pour eux c'est comme c'est un
dessinateur c'est un magicien donc ça se
voit dans leurs yeux 7
voilà c'était les règlements par rapport
à sa
merci de nous avoir suivis c'est donc la
fin de cette édition du 7 8 les invités
7,8 les invités qui reviendra à demain
avec notamment nicolas bauer c'est un
ancien élu du front national il siège
dans l'opposition elle en cours et elle
dénonce aujourd'hui la mise à l'écart
dont il serait l'objet par les instances
nationales de son parti très bonne
soirée
[Musique]